oh my my bro
hello hi i look extra small today what are you talking about
can't you see me i'm a giant in this field in this nice
background i'm like I'm like 10 feet tall
My my boo But sneak upon the mine So they don't know to
explode I have to crawl on it I have to crawl on it I get it
I get it I get it I get it I get it I get it I get it Wait,
watch this.
I'm crawling?
Which one is it?
Wait, it worked.
Guys, it worked!
It actually worked!
Look at that!
Now, everybody!
I remember how to play this game For anybody who doesn't
know Wait one second
One moment please For anybody that doesn't know I don't I
learned how to play this game Last week I learned how to
play this game Last week Yeah Crazy right crazy right wait
really yeah really and this is my second time playing it you
explode with cuteness I am the mind sweeper I am I am I and
so it was part of my goals last year to beat this game.
And I also feel like it's not it's not impressive if I don't
beat it on expert.
We're gonna we're gonna do it, baby.
Maid finally learns how to sweep.
Mito sweep!
Your time is ticking?
Are you trying to say that I might, that I need to have a
baby right now?
Because that's usually what that means when you say that to
a lady.
The corner or the timer in the corner?
Oh, yeah.
Last week, it took about 45 minutes to try and solve one of
these bad boys.
You know, Mind Sweeper is not for the week, I think.
Happy Friday, Minto.
Happy Friday!
Woo!
Wow!
So,
thank you for Zephyr chat.
I'm sure you and Doki are very proud.
Hmm.
I don't think Doki is proud of anybody.
You're a blast to watch?
A blast to watch, Min.
You put that boo in.
Boom!
So, and Boomer for 10% off Gamer Sups.
Yeah!
So, Gamer Sups will send me, like, free stuff, right?
Like, I had to tell them that I couldn't take any more of
their, like, actual merch, which is very nice that they
send.
Every time they do a drop, they send something.
So if it's, like, they send, like, all of the stuff, too.
Like, all the new flavors to me, and also, all of the...
like if there's like clothes or whatever the set comes with
it's it's it's i had to tell them though i have no more
space please don't send me anything else i have the amount
of cups i got was insane but but um uh still still send me
like the the like i said the flavors and things or if they
come out with a new product and um they came out with
something hold on what was it I think I uh they literally
told me this today gamer raid and so they had sent me some
gamer raid but um so I use like a like a forwarding service
right for like all my mail because you know i'm i'm safe
like that but um before the gamer raid they sent me like
cans of cans uh of some of the stuff that they had i
couldn't have it because it's carbonated but um um
you know cans are quite heavy right and so is apparently
this gamer aid because whenever i need to ship it from my
forwarding service to me uh the shipping is over a hundred
dollars and sometimes it would be like that um with the with
the merch as well and i was like and it was like almost
monthly that i was getting this stuff and i was like oh my
god i'm spending $100 to ship it all to me.
Anytime you're moving water around, it's gotta be heavy.
I'm like, oh, no.
No.
The most expensive free stuff.
I know.
She doesn't know that's how much we pay for it.
That's not.
You shouldn't be.
Mindsweeper tip Don't click yourself Because you are the ba
J-Man J-Man I want to play Half-Life The new Not new, sorry
The other Half-Life episodes I gotta get through The year is
2009 Your dial-up internet just went down You are playing
Mindsweeper And listening to Kalimba Ninja Tuna My Mr.
Scruff on Loop What is that?
That's how I feel Buying anything off AmiYami now I had to,
I had to forego some orders.
I had to be like, because one of the things that I got from
the Metal Gear pre-order, Metal Gear Delta pre-order, was
the Ami Ami exclusive was a skateboard deck.
And I had this stuff.
Actually, I didn't even check what the shipping was.
I was too scared.
I was a pet man, thank you.
I had some sample packets sitting around an order and
genuinely of a surprise that it was pretty good.
Yeah, it's pretty good.
17 months.
Crimson Dhaka!
No, I'm just kidding.
I'm always...
I live in a populous USA city.
Two cans of subs is $80 before shipping.
What's a populous?
Like a popular city?
I live in the popular city which starts at like 11 dollars
use them creator codes people wait where is that what's the
popular city why is it so expensive the shipping I just want
a fat amount at a casino game let's go Walter why mind if I
share bits of my wins to my favorite girls.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Happy New Year.
You're not late at all.
It's only the 9th.
Happy New Year!
You know what's crazy too?
I thought about...
Not only just, I guess shipping is expensive, but also plane
tickets have been so expensive.
I was like, I think I'll...
You guys, I was gonna do it.
I was gonna take a weekend and I was gonna go to Disney and
I was gonna go ride dinosaur one more time because I just
couldn't fathom not riding it ever again and I looked up
plane tickets to Orlando 500 I'm on the east coast mind you
500 dollars USD
So, uh, needless to say.
And that's before Disney tickets, before hotel, anything.
I was, I was appalled and disgusted.
I was like, you, you can't, you can't, you can't do this.
That's a robbery.
I'm on the East Coast.
That's like just a couple of hours.
hours oh my god is that cheap no it's usually like half that
or more sometimes craziness you didn't want to drive i
didn't want to be gone from streaming for so long i was like
i don't want to i wanted it to really be like a quick thing
like in and out boom boom I go ride it.
I go back home.
I was like, you know, I'm ready to, you know, I just wanted
to go say bye to it.
But man, oh, $500.
That's like flying to the West Coast, which is like a very,
like five hours from the East Coast.
It's craziness.
Craziness.
And I've never done like a road trip.
That would take way too long.
streaming on the road you guys would hear my road rage
didn't you love me and thank you thank you so much so much
so much so much thank you for the gift of memberships before
stream too thank you thank you almost as bad for me to go to
cali from denmark i feel like wait how long of a flight is
that Watched your one-shot VODs, curious if you ever played
Mother 3.
I've never played any of, like, the Earthbound or Mother
Games before.
Bite size!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Happy birthday.
11 hours, give or take.
Oh, that's not so bad.
That's not so bad.
I'm so broken by flights to Japan.
I'm like, you know, anything, like...
Like, 10 hours?
Wow, sure.
Nine hours?
Wow, that's not so bad.
I'm seeing 440 for round trip to flight from my place to
Orlando for tomorrow.
You could go!
That's so expensive though.
Well, I don't know where you are if you're a West Coast or
what.
Mother 3, Vention, please play it, please.
Oh my gosh.
No, for BS.
Thank you so much for the Hakka Super.
Thank you.
Shadow, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Howdy, long time?
in her first time caller, how did it go down being asked to
do bakamitai in the style of Donna Burke?
It's not Donna Burke?
Cynthia Rousey Snake Eater but um they just contacted me
they were like hey we're doing like a thing for bakamitai um
we had the idea for uh bakamitai but but as with the melody
of Snake Eater I mean wait no Opposite.
Snake eater, but the melody of bakamitai.
We thought you would be really good for it.
If you...
If you're interested.
Wow, it's $500 plus to fly to Orlando too.
Two hour drive!
What's going on in Orlando?
oh my god while i was there though okay while i was there
you guys i learned about the pop tart bowl which i first
thought was a pop tart convention i was like do i need to
extend my dates so that i can go to the pop tart convention
and try a bunch of different kinds of pop tarts no don't be
fooled it's football but but hold on it's college football
but but it's not just any football you guys there are okay
it's like a cult i learned this you first there are pop-tart
mascots right there are pop-tart mascots the game begins the
game begins with them honoring the former pop-tart from last
year's pop-tart bowl okay and then at the end the chosen
pop-tart the winning pop tart gets sacrificed into an omega
giant huge it's a it's i was about to say live size but a
live size toaster would just be a regular size toaster no no
no it is a massive toaster that they sacrifice the pop tarts
fall into and then it cooks into a giant pop tart and i
don't know what they do with it i don't think everybody gets
one but I would be kind of fun if you get a little piece of
the giant pop-tart and he can eat it.
And that's the pop-tart bowl.
And at first I was like, ah, man, it's football.
Yuck.
I thought it was going to be a pop-tart convention, but no.
Now I feel like I should have gone so that I could see the
sacrifice of the pop-tart.
As long as the winning pop-tart is always brown sugar
cinnamon, we're good.
No, Oreo, Oreo, Oreo, Oreo, Oreo, cookie, cream, cookie.
cream finally a way to make football interesting you should
go we should go to the pop-tart bowl next year we should go
I actually don't like pop-tarts that much but I was very
excited about the idea of like a convention that was when I
was in Florida for holiday Matsuri I was like man what is
America doing sometimes I wonder.
It's kind of fun, though, no?
And then the Pop-Tarts are out there.
Like all the people in the Pop-Tart mascots are out there
and they're being silly, goofy.
And then one gets killed and eaten and devoured in front of
the masses.
That's a modern day, like, you know, they used to do an
execution in, like, the courtyard of little towns.
That's a modern day execution, now, isn't it?
They're like beheading?
No, no.
We cook them now.
That Pop-Tart's going straight into the toast.
So strange.
The Pop-Tart's bowl and the Duke's Mayo Bowl.
Maybe a less yummy food made sure people had a good time.
What?
I've never heard of the Mayo Bowl.
That sounds terrible.
You missed your opportunity to complete the ritual.
No!
I had a dream.
I had a dream the other night that...
That...
Oh, what was it now?
What was it?
Uh...
That like a party.
Oh, I remember!
I was I was a ballet I was a ballerina and I got chosen to
be the lead ballerina in a dance in like a in a performance
and I was like yippee so I held a party and someone that
came to the party was like okay do you guys remember there's
that episode of like the twilight zone where there's a
little boy that like is basically god and can control
everything and so everyone bends to his will make him upset
it was basically that this this girl comes to my party and
and and i'm like oh oh it's january 24th the 31st s j u m oh
my god no doubt you sending me plane tickets thank you
though um
um that episode yeah it was freaky right uh but um the
little girl like wanted something i don't remember what it
was and walter white was there from breaking bad and he was
like he was like i don't want to he him and his big old ego
his big old big stinking ego was like i don't want to do and
so she got really mad and she triggered the end of the world
and the end of the world all i was gonna do is be a
ballerina and walter white said that ain't happening and so
i remember being it was like like it was orange kind of like
the color grading in the breaking bad show right but thank
you for the super chat but um but it was like because it was
like you know know uh uh it was orange from all the fire um
and i remember people like dancing out in the parking lots
and just kind of being like the world is ending the world is
ending oh walter white's fault yeah the mexico filter i
don't think i was in mexico though i don't think so this one
should be safe
yeah no and then this one's not safe but then this one these
two are also not safe because of the two right so mine's
reaper dreams have meanings meanwhile dreams yeah They're
continuing Malcolm in the middle on Hulu.
Is he Malcolm in the front?
Malcolm in the back?
Does he ever get out of the middle?
Orange apocalypse.
What is Crimson One?
Read Twilight Zone.
A local TV mogul where I'm from had in his will that the
station he owned would have a Twilight Zone marathon when he
died.
Did they?
Yeah, sorry, we're playing mine, Sweeper.
She's the middle child, so no.
We could change that.
I'm bored, gang, because I'm way behind.
But the thumbnail's amazing.
Thanks, Rooks!
See you later.
Whoa, whoa, sorry, did you hear that?
Sorry, that was my...
Sorry, I okay, I okay.
That was my headphones brushing against my mic.
Sorry.
Alrighty, alright, this one, not safe.
Okay, I should lock in, but I'm also just wanting to talk.
You can just click whatever?
Wow, wee!
That actually...
did me some good so these two and then this one very nice
clicking anything is actually maybe a valid strut i have
complete faith in you thank you
i'm a napling hanging out with you in the eyeballs because
i'm avoiding outer wild spoilers watching it earlier.
Wait, it shouldn't...
The video shouldn't still be going, right?
Before you go boom today, I have faith in you.
Can I borrow $5?
Thanks!
Why would you give me $5 then?
If you're wanting to borrow it.
Oh, it ended 20 minutes ago.
Yeah, that's what I thought.
The past Nimeo is so close.
The thing is, is I don't remember.
Like, I very vaguely remember things from the DLC so I'm
like I'm like oh because I played it I played it um but I'm
like her trying to figure out I'm watching her trying to
figure out things and I'm also like oh yeah how did you do
that oh yeah how was that supposed to be done you know I
can't remember
DLC is hard.
It was.
I remember.
I think she's really...
It's really impressive that she's playing it without chat
too.
Because for me, I would be like...
I'm like, hint!
Hint!
Help!
Help me!
Every game is really...
replayable if you forget everything exactly but there are
some things of outer wilds i think it's really the impact of
the ending with outer wilds you know what i mean and and
like especially the main game now that i know with like the
the fishies and stuff and you know whatever whatever It's
like Like That I don't think I'll ever forget You know And
so I'm like Yeah You know I could forget like How to do
certain tiny puzzles But
No spoilers I'm not giving spoilers I just said fishies
That's all And then also The ending of the DLC And
everything too Like I just feel like The ending sticks out
to me more than like all the little puzzles and the ending
is the most important part.
So...
That sounds fishy.
They're fishy on the bramble.
All you have to do is go into the bramble and you see them
immediately.
So...
Yeah.
Oh well.
Maybe, maybe in like 100 years I could replay it and be
like, oh yeah!
Oh yeah!
Oh, I love Outer Wilds, I love it.
I'm gonna click here.
Oh!
Guys!
I might be a genius.
Dan, Dan!
Holy luck.
It ain't luck, baby.
it's all skill it's all skill it's all up here in my noggin
you hear that that's the lucky coin i ate
yeah that's that lucky coin rattling around in there
let's see what else we got here we can do do this one, we
could do this one, we could do this one, we could do this
one.
I love corner ones.
Corner one, corner one.
I'm already at 79.
Let's go.
Careful, it might hit the brain cell.
What?
What brain cell?
Still got one more corner one.
I do?
Oh, I see it.
Right here.
That's just the brains, though.
Let's see what else we got.
I will, I will lock in, because I do.
I want to beat this.
I do.
I want to beat Mind Sweeper.
That means this one's safe.
I like how the guy goes
And that means this one is safe.
This one is safe.
Yeah.
Which means it has to be that one.
She can be the...
I want to.
I'll let R click on a number.
Reveal all unflagged squares around that number.
Hold for intense Best VTuber ever is playing Best game ever
Yeah That would mean The best VTuber ever is
I feel like anyone that Any said VTuber would be a
controversial take
You know if you left and right click at the same time on a
number of magic happens hmm i don't know if i believe true
oh yeah did a kizuna i get get is that is that real that
kizuna i will be in fortnight do we finally have i honestly
thought it was going to be a hololive member in fortnight
first
allegedly or middle click oh I can middle click let's try
here whoa wait what's going on here wait what is that why is
it like that whoa it's showing me whoa what what is that
over number oh it's showing everything that it touches simba
everything the the squares touch is our kingdom click near a
flag wait what just happened wait why did that happen wait
that scared me wait what just happened there huh
feel safe tiles if you flagged correctly no way no that's
not how it works because there's oh i i get it i see what's
me what nandato wait this one's safe then i thought it was a
corner when i was i saw i'm i'm very i'm feeling i'm really
seeing things now you know like this one this one this is a
corner like You know what I mean?
It's a shortcut.
It lets you play fast.
Oh my god.
That's craziness.
She's starting to believe.
I know, I know, I am, I am.
I'm starting to believe.
But then sometimes I'm also...
The numbers.
narrative number 76 more minds to go but 76 but not the
opposite way around the other way around
i admit please i didn't say it so what else did i'm not as
brain-rodded as you guys i'm not as brain-rodded as you guys
it doesn't come to me so quickly when someone makes that You
know?
So the three can also be cleared.
Like so.
Right, because it can only touch one, two, three.
Right?
Right.
Ah, yeah, baby.
In that case, okay.
So then this one is safe.
Scary.
Still scary touching it though.
Which means that one is not safe.
One, two.
Safe.
Oh my gosh.
Crazy.
Why did it open up like that?
Why did it kind of scare me?
This one is safe.
Not safe.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's so much happening.
Hold on.
What if I Beat it first try.
Wait, I think I just jinxed myself.
Welcome back, Gort.
Nice profile picture.
The Windows XP background is cracking me up.
Did you guys ever have, like, OS time?
Replace your sounds on, like, XP time.
Replace your sounds on your computer.
Okay.
A long time ago, yeah, me too!
Why can't we bring OS-Tan back?
Probably though, 11-Tan would be not great.
Me too, I'm just up as Asala on at Magfest this weekend.
I'm thinking of you.
I love you.
My kamiyoshi, please marry me.
Evan!
Are you drunk?
wait wait wait you're asking me that so that wait okay wait
i get it i'm seeing the vision you're asking me that so that
at the wedding then you would be like be like i've double
crossed you i'm actually getting married to a snake and then
i would be like oh Baby.
I get it, I get it, I get it, I get it, I get it, I get it.
And I would be sad, too, because I love Os a lot.
But...
At the same time...
Who would be Snake, though?
Raise your hand!
Raise your hand if you would interrupt my wedding.
And then marry...
I've been dressed up as Ocelot.
I'll cosplay Ocelot for you whenever you want, please make.
Go sober up!
I'm glad you're having fun at Magfest!
You got a cold shower!
It's so chill, bro.
Here, Minto here.
Wait, when are you going to be Snake?
But you're not marrying me.
You're marrying Evan.
Let's all make that very clear.
I'm literally him.
You are literally him.
Froggy.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Hello.
I saw I can be with two people because he has two hands.
Wait, where are we in the timeline?
I made you laugh so it was worth it.
drink water now yeah yeah i'll pat your head go go go drink
some water now go drink some go drink some water buddy you
deserve it go go go kick it make sure it's only friday make
sure that you're nice and coherent for the rest of the
weekend you know very sad oh my gosh wait it's so exciting i
could see you in the dent into discord I thought that
earlier.
I was like, because you don't have Twitter.
Can I come to the wedding dressed as Naomi?
Only if you...
Wait.
Only if you interrupt it many times.
You have to be like...
You have to always make it about yourself.
Wait.
I kind of want to do like a costume, like a roleplay party.
not a role-playing party you know one thing I oh my gosh I
saw while I was in Orlando was a murder mystery like theater
dinner show and I've never done one of those before oh I
wanted to go so bad but I'm also nervous what if I'm the one
who dies and then I can't participate and then I'm just
laying there in my lake in my mesh And I'm like, ah, man.
You're already dead.
No, no.
I'm dead, like, for real.
But in the context of the murder mystery show, I'm supposed
to be alive, you know?
And then someone could kill me.
And I'm like, they're like, at any time I like try to eat my
food or something, they come up to me and they're like,
we're gonna.
You better close that mouth a little messy.
You are not finishing your food until we find this.
It's murder, okay.
They take it very seriously.
What song are you walking down the aisle to, Minto?
You know I've thought about this before.
Something Metal Gear.
Evan, are you okay?
How much did you drink tonight?
Twelve shots.
This time I had twelve shots.
You forgot the throw up emoji.
You would be over the toilet at that point, buddy.
Who will officiate a wedding for this MGS crew?
Campbell.
Sir, I'm dead for my day job, please.
Can I please be alive?
I just want to taste.
I want to know the taste of what it feels like to be a
normal human girl.
for one day it's like that it's like that scene in Casper I
just I just want to feel the love I just want to feel
something okay I'm over I went to a charity murder mystery
dinner spaghetti dinner For a cat, oh my gosh, I want to be
getting so much right now.
For a cat shelter once, it was a fantastic overlap of
theater people and cat people.
10 out of 10 recommend attending murder mystery dinners are
fun.
But also, what if it's not a very popular location and
you're the only one in the crowd?
And they're like, well, this is awkward.
You're at the altar and when the grooms turn to say, I do,
he starts activating the optional code at conversation
instead.
it's just like do you take this what this this wait what did
they say do you take this ghost to be your lawfully wedded
wife and he says i'm going offline Michael welcome to my
bishop thank you
and Adonai welcome to my bishop thank you Yes, I do.
The whole ceremony is conducted via codec.
Oh my gosh, what if?
What if?
To get to the altar?
It was like a sneaking mission, right?
I have a friend called Cyberfishy.
I know Cyberfishy, who doesn't think she'll make it to
Off-Kai this year.
You're her kamiyoshi, can you tell her to lock in?
Wait, no, Cyberfishy!
I wanna see you.
I want to see you!
Please!
Come to Off-Kai!
There will be lots of Minto around, so...
Off-Kai is going to be full of Minto.
You got this!
What if you got married on a field of white flowers?
And then I had to shoot the person I was marrying?
There can only be one married.
Wait.
One...
Uh...
There can only...
Oh...
Uh...
There...
Ah...
One spouse.
Minto, what if the dress is the box?
Well, you're just trying to get me in my cardboard dress
again.
I know what you guys are doing.
I know your game.
You're just trying to get me in in the cardboard dress
again.
Highlander MGS crossover.
Hey, hang, no.
Are you sure?
Are you sure about that?
This one, not safe.
I'm still playing the game, don't worry.
Safe.
I'm still playing.
Pinto holds snake, holds Ocelot's hand while the background
plays the winner.
The winner takes it off.
Honestly, I chose Mind Sweeper today because I was also
like, I think I've just got a one.
Like I knew that with Mind Sweeper, I would just be able to
like yapp and have like just just kind of take it easy, so
that was also partially why I chose it.
Safe.
I think I'm understanding the game now.
Yes, I like the number.
Best way to show up to a wedding is either Halo Jump or via
One Man SDV.
Bride is OSP.
This is becoming more and more realistic like real like we
could really plan this i think oh my gosh though i think
actually like a a you know how like wedding planners are a
thing a wedding planner who specializes in doing video game
themed uh wedding ceremonies would be like like she has it
all planned out like what kind of cake you get what kind of
decorations you have because like like video game anime
themed weddings are like actually quite common I think it's
like I think I need to patent that I think I need to I think
I need to like get on that you'd be making Buku books I
think there's a huge market for that you imagine having like
a super classy but also like super nerdy um Zelda, Zelda
themed wedding, you know?
Boo-Koo books, exactly!
I would like to thank Eating Mike Tyson's A-S-S.
For introducing me to it!
Oh my gosh, Brian!
Thank you!
Thanks for sticking around!
Thank you to the legend.
It's okay if you beat the game, we can just...
Just watch some more of your amazing TikToks.
Yeah, you like my TikTok.
If you haven't joined the Densetsu Twitter yet, you should
because I have a channel all for my TikToks.
And last night I was dino posting.
If the dress is in the deal, then I might need to steal
both.
Yeah, you might.
Hey, Mons with a dorky ghost.
Oh, you call it a dork.
Thank you, Felix.
Thank you.
It was a lot of fun.
I've just kind of been popping in there.
I don't.
I, um, you know, I, I'm in a few, like, like, am I a few?
I mean, like, extremely few discords.
And I only may be talking one sometimes.
So, you know, believe it or not, I'm extremely, like, um,
talk deprived.
And so...
so when like they were like oh you know steiner steiner here
was like we're gonna make like a dentitsu um uh discord feel
free to join or not join it's up to you and you know you
don't have to chat in it at all or anything it's all up to
you but i like just have fun with it glad you can yapp in
there but yeah it's like no pressure yapp and i you so it's
just kind of fun for me because like like i said i've never
been in like a discord where i'm like very active or talking
a lot so live your time welcome to membership thank you hey
minto would you like to use your skills to plan my video
game anime themed wedding either way you are invited as the
bride
Wait a minute Is this Actually, have you guys heard about
this?
Like sometimes It's like, I think it's like an East Asian
Not common thing for sure, but I had a part time sometimes
Thank you Thank you so much But sometimes when like someone
when like someone passes away early like you know at a young
age like like you know say 19 for example sometimes the
parents will be like okay we're going to we're going to find
somebody that will marry my son or daughter's spirit so that
they the spirit can then feel fulfilled and move on
Have you guys ever heard of that before?
It's kind of depressing.
I thought that was an Asian thing.
Yeah, yeah, that's why I think.
I've heard of it in, like, East Asia, but I don't know if
it's...
I don't think it's very common, but it is a thing.
In your ghostly experience, does it ever work?
Well, like, I feel bad for the living person because...
it's like they have to like they have to like what's the
word be married to the person for like a certain amount of
time I think it's mostly though like psychics that like scam
people maybe I don't know I don't think I've ever been
married to a living person and then what am I supposed to do
when their time is up do I get a spiritual divorce I They
just...
What am I supposed to do?
I feel like the spirit should also get a say in this.
I feel like that too.
What if I really...
What if I'm like, hey, this person is...
I don't mean from scam psychics.
What if I'm like, oh gosh, this person's living situation is
horrible.
Like, they're disgusting.
Can't wait for the Minto lizard postings.
Dinosaur posting is pretty close.
Steal their soul, Yandere style, so they can't leave you.
Spiritual divorce is indeed a word I never thought I'd hear
today.
Yeah, well...
You never know.
Yeah, what about a prenup?
I don't know.
Do you need a prenup?
Divorce via Ouija board.
Do you want a divorce?
Little, the little planchette moves over to, yes.
I take the dog.
Planchette moves.
No.
Y-E-S-N-T.
Yes, it.
Then, you gotta really, you gotta, you gotta give an answer
that, like, will keep them on their toes.
Do you want a divorce?
Ouija board just spells out, I can change.
Do we need ghost lawyers?
Yeah, in that case, like, what if...
What if, like, the person that died, you know, obviously
they left behind things that they...
owned does this does the does the wife or the husband
whoever married the spirit do they then get the things very
very confusing this is getting complicated yeah
very very interesting hmm but i have i have heard stories of
like people being like I had a relationship with a ghost and
the ghost and I would be like we'd have me and ghost would
have funky funky time I've heard of that before and I say
it's fun being the Lulu maybe I think
consult the board this planchette driven marriage drama
brought to you by bro
this is weird why can't they marry Hatsune Miku like normal
people yeah or the Eiffel Tower
people are so funny huh what the fuck is that what they're
calling it now funky funky time what else am I supposed to
call it they they do the bow chicka wow wow Maybe.
Ma 'am, you are grown an adult.
I have been mentally 19 for a very long time.
What do you want from me, huh?
That pin is wrong.
This one?
Oh, you're right.
I thought this was a corner.
You're right.
Now it's a corner.
Thank
you.
Mentally stunted Oshi.
Why are you guys saying that number, those two numbers?
Why?
Middle click them once.
Oh my gosh.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Wow!
You can do the four in the top left.
This way?
One, two, three, four.
Yes, we can.
It's just completely surrounded.
You're surrounded.
Put your hands up.
Bada-dang.
And now that I've had the chance to eat some food and drink
some water,
Evan, it's been like 10 minutes!
Evan!
What?
You haven't!
That quickly!
Thanks for the fun stream.
If time allows, I dare you!
To complete a minesweeper board without flagging any mines.
Maybe we could do that!
Okay.
Once I beat an expert one We'll try that We'll try that
On an easy board Oh
Flag Yes, Joe Welcome to Mambu Share After a good birthday
My kamiyoshi is streaming Hashtag Bless Hashtag Hashtag
blessed, hashtag lucky, Itachi, happy birthday, happy, happy
birthday.
Middle clicks are so satisfying.
Here, I'll do one again.
Oh, wait, wait.
I'll do one again.
Oh, well, then.
This is expert.
I know.
Wait, did I say expert?
Wait, no, after I complete this one, we'll do it on like an
easy board, the easier board.
board, easy board.
One, two.
Whoops.
I was answering the guy's question.
Oh, okay, sorry.
I didn't know.
Sometimes my brain moves very fast and I don't know if I
misspeak or something.
let's see
my brain my brain's always braining it's just braining
sometimes a little funny funnier than others especially
streaming because I'm so I'm focused on multiple things at
once so I'm like it's like when you're talking and writing
something you know you're like typing something and you type
what you say Kind of similar to that.
We love your brand.
I'm glad.
99 Metal Gear Solid.
99% Metal Gear Solid 1% stream.
Yeah.
Sometimes it says subscriber only mode, but I am subbed.
First of all, thank you for subscribing.
Second of all, you're not the only one.
YouTube has been really funky.
funky like recently a lot of people are saying that they're
having issues with this one is safe
i middle clicked because i was scared yeah i do the
subscriber mode because it helps keep out spam like bot
messages coming in so easily you know what i mean but um
sorry that it's been kind of buggy for you guys.
Middle click, the three at the top.
Which one?
This one?
Oh, you're right.
Yeah, one, two, three.
Thank you!
One.
One, two.
Okay.
This one is free.
So it has to be...
Oh wait, it could be that one or that one.
Okay.
Four?
We've gotten up to six, baby.
I love the way Minto's brain works so much.
Except when it's being mean to her.
Hey!
Max is eight?
Oh, I guess because it would be like one, two, three, four,
five, six, 7, 8, and then the 8 right there.
How rare is that, though?
I feel like 8 has to be, like, super rare, right?
Never seen it.
It's very, very rare.
Yeah, it must be.
How exciting if one day we got it.
That'd be so cool.
Fun multitask mistake for me was in the first grade.
I was supposed to start the Pledge of Allegiance, but I was
reading a Sesame Street book and I was saying whatever
Grover was saying.
Not Grover.
If mint was a soda flavor, would it be Coke Zero Sugar?
Because...
Because why?
I pledge allegiance to Grover.
Of the...
Of...
The United Sesame Streets.
You learned how to play Mindsaber from old college humor
sketch.
No way.
This one's clean.
Nice.
Then it must be this one.
Because one, two, three.
Clean.
Sorry, I will play the game.
I am playing.
Just, you know, on my own terms.
Not clean.
I was wrong!
Wait, how was I wrong?
Wait.
What's
up there?
Dang it, I didn't see the connecting there.
No!
Oh well.
I'm gonna do this one.
I'm gonna also do this one.
Two.
A simple two.
Here.
Another simple two.
Bam.
Okay, we can start with this.
There we go.
And there.
Nice.
We got three corners.
Which would you give up?
Lasagna or shrimp scampi?
I love shrimp scampi.
I would give up.
I don't like lasagna that much, actually, so goodbye,
goodbye, goodbye.
Give me shrimp scampy every day.
That was some lemon juice on top.
Do you notice the face it makes when you click?
Yeah!
I like it.
Safe.
Whoa!
Say...
Save?
Oh, okay, four.
Corner.
Save.
I'll take all the lasagna.
Okay, you can have it.
Top right corner, I dare you.
I do it.
I'm not afraid.
That's the funny thing about being dead.
I'm not afraid of death.
What am I gonna do?
Blow up.
Oh, gosh, mom, I'm blowing up on the internet.
Might be a bad thing.
Might not be great, actually.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, no.
It's like the good and bad thing about, like, going viral,
you know?
It's like...
You'll get then...
You'll then get, like, the people that are...
scary and unhinged that that start to pay attention to you
too and you're like oh no oh no oh no
they come out of the woodwork I know I'm very honestly like
I'm very what's the word comfortable with my size because it
is like I'm I feel very like i don't i'm not the i'm not the
biggest obviously but it's like i i feel like it's chill
enough you know it's pretty nice during the yaps and the
sweeping thanks minto thanks artemaris welcome back your
usars yeah yeah yeah yeah mint is a liar she stole billions
I'll never admit it Minto likes being short confirmed I You
know I wanted to be really tall A long time ago I wish I was
like Like six foot tall I wanted to be like so tall And then
You know I thought about it for like planes and stuff
Actually I don't mind at all and also it's funny because
like um I once I saw a video that was like this is the POV
of of um like a POV of someone in a kitchen at 150
centimeters right so like about 5 feet and um and it was
funny because the comments were like oh this feels so much
more comfortable than like seeing the pov of someone at six
feet that was too scary i was i was terrified for my for my
life and that that you know i was like okay you know but it
is very inconvenient um luckily i can float but um if i'm
possessing somebody i can't reach i can't reach like the
dishes like if i'm trying or a plate.
It's very inconvenient.
Short propaganda?
No.
No!
It's better!
Guy who gets vertigo watching a six-foot POV.
Can you ride roller coasters?
Yeah.
I can ride any roller coaster.
I was five foot nothing up until like 15.
Now I'm six foot.
How did that happen?
What kind of growth spurt did you have?
Whatever size you are, that's the perfect size.
Thank you.
Also, thank you so much for the redirect, Mero.
Welcome, welcome.
Welcome, welcome everybody.
This one must be bud.
So then this is safe.
Wait, safe.
Paperbacks!
Thank you for the gifted.
There we go.
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
I had a growth spurt.
Can't relate.
Thank you, STO2.
Thank you for the gift, dad.
Rest in glitch race.
Ducky, thank you for the gift, dad.
We can tell.
My body for gore.
Imagine growing.
It's supposed to hurt, though, no?
Like when you...
It's right click.
Okay, good.
Just when I was getting scared for a second.
It hurts when your body grows, though, doesn't it?
That should be, yeah.
Choo-choo.
So then this is safe.
Yeah.
A bit.
There are growing pains.
Why would it hurt?
Because you're stretching.
Right?
I suffered so much in my childhood from growing pains.
Maybe you guys just don't remember because you're old.
I'm a fresh, you know, 19.
I don't
know why, but Minto's extra cute tonight.
Let's see.
gonna do it I'm gonna random click no oh
I was about to say wait a second though this is this is this
oh this one right there oops we had a good run going for us
guys my bad my bad I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
but look how many more we got rid of look at that look how
many more we cleared up Wait.
The ding.
This one is all, these are also clear.
She's gonna be awesome at this one.
She actually focuses.
That's the hard part is the focus.
You know what I mean?
That's the hard part.
Focus.
You gotta lock in.
Okay.
this is the what this is this is where we lock in guys it is
scary windy my house is shaking shaking in these oh i
thought it said guests i was like you have friends over and
they're like shivering can you bestow your ghostly
protection on me so i don't die i don't think that's i'd
like to do the opposite of that i don't think that's how it
I want to play a mind sweeper clone that makes cute minto
noises when I click.
Okay, there's gotta be a game dev in the chat.
You know what to do.
You know what to make.
Oh wait, this is good.
This is clear.
Yeah.
Clear.
I will do the sounds.
I could be like, save.
Save.
Jay, welcome back!
Hi, I am GameDev.
If you want to, you could.
Save.
And then if you accidentally click a bomb, it goes, Save.
Oh, just kidding!
What would be the sound effect for explosion?
That's my Donald Duck impression.
If there was an explosion, it would be like, Kaplowy!
Save.
Roadrunner cartoons.
Let's see, what do we got here?
Safe.
Oh, oops, safe.
The one on the left middle by the flag.
Oh, this one on the left.
one safe wow big safe let's go nice not safe no help no we
help here we help here we do we do there's a hundred percent
help please help me help me i'm getting it though it's
really just a matter see a move or not, you know what I
mean?
But for the rules of the game, I think I get it.
I think I get it.
Elpers in chat.
I'm an elpa.
Oh, whoops.
Oh my god, I almost...
Middle click is scary because sometimes I accidentally click
on the wrong thing.
That's scary.
That's so scary.
Holy canoli, that would have been bad.
There's a mine on your nose.
We'll boop it and flag it safe for you.
Wait.
It tickles.
This one is not safe.
One, two.
And so this one is not safe.
Yes.
I got to ride in the back of a car.
cop car today let's go oh
let's go oh dog are you okay dog dog all right let's see
being tall at a young age sucked people mistook me as a
threat when i was playing at my local park oh no i was too
big for certain rides it's also i was often asked to pay
full price at events and not allowed to order kids meals
that's so sad what's the minto flag sound safe oh wait no
that's wrong it would be Right row Not here Uh oh Let's see
Do you guys see any moves that I could make I'm looking I'm
looking Driver's got a DUI and the cops gave me a ride back
into town I'm glad you're okay Oh my goodness Oh I wish,
though, that anybody could get a kid's meal.
Sometimes I just want a smaller meal, you know?
Two top middle.
Ah, thank you.
Right there.
Oh, oh, thank you, thank you.
Nice.
Thank you, thank you.
Sometimes, though, like, some places will let you.
But some restaurants are, like, really...
strict about it you know especially it's easier to get away
with it at like a fast food place if you're like going
through drive-through or you know just ordering but if
you're like at a sit-down restaurant usually they'll like
they'll be like no way old man bottom right too
oh this one i see i see okay then that one's good that one's
good this one's good nice very nice and so it must be this
one because it'd be boom boom boom and one two three so this
one's good yeah good good that's good this one good oh my
gosh I'm middle-clicking everything now uh-oh I mean this is
gonna get me in trouble I swear it's gonna get me in trouble
guys one One, two, one, two, okay.
We're sweeping, we're sweeping!
You can do that five.
Oh, there is a five!
I didn't even see it.
One, two, three, four, five.
Yeah!
That knocked out a ton, didn't it?
Craziness.
And then also, we will be able to do this three, right?
One, two.
Three.
Yeah.
And then this two.
One, two.
So this is good.
Hummer, hummer.
Hummer, hummer, hummer.
Remember at perpetually...
Remember being perpetually nine years old to get kids'
prices up over there.
Well, let's see.
I know you guys yell at me at places to look, but I would
also like to find them myself.
You know.
One, two.
I would like to find them myself before I rely on you guys
and your expertise, okay?
So if you think I'm ignoring you, I probably am.
Oh!
She hates us.
No!
One.
Never.
Someone.
One.
I mean someone.
Someone.
Someone else.
This is a corn.
Oh.
Uh, this one.
There we go.
Oh, misclick.
A birthday.
Minto Bind Sweeper's Dream on my birthday.
You got this man.
I believe in you.
I'm Peter.
Happy birthday.
Happy, happy birthday.
Looking cute, Minto.
Thank you.
Oh, my gosh.
I thought my clock.
I thought it had been.
Oh, my gosh.
I thought it had been two and a half hours already.
I was like, there's no.
way but my clock uh the i have a i have a like a a clock and
the i wasn't looking at my computer clock i was looking at
it and i have a koharu standy in front of it and it blocked
the part that made it look like eight so i thought it was
nine and i was like what where did the time go sorry for the
winded explanation
A clock you say.
Yes, yes, I might have a clock.
I might partake in the, you know, the time.
Mito, sweeto, Mito, cuteo!
Shadow Chama!
Thank you for this, everybody!
I love you.
I like when you beat Mind Sweeper and the smiley face guy is
like...
Glasses.
I've never beat Mind Sweeper, so I'm really...
I want that experience.
I want that.
I want to see that guy.
I've never beaten it.
Today is the day.
Spoilers.
Not the Mind Sweeper spoilers.
Oh my god.
Did you start with hard mode?
Started with hard mode.
Da-den.
Oh, nice, nice.
I like when we clear more than two things.
Okay.
Sometimes in the end it's 50-50.
I know, that's what happened to me last.
time and what was my downfall but i believe i believe here
look we haven't even gotten to 999 yet we're kind of killing
it wait it has to be this one one two three okay at this
pace hey hey we're going at minto pace okay please please
understand Have you watched Apple BBC prehistoric planet
season 1 and 2?
No.
I haven't.
I don't think I...
I'm pretty sure I canceled Apple TV after Severance.
And then once Severance comes back, I'll get it again.
That's how I...
That's how I work.
I don't really have, like, any subscription services.
Unless, like, I want to watch something and then I get rid
of it.
Pluribus.
What's that?
What's pluribus?
Not spoilers.
Cannot believe.
It's about slimes.
From the Directors of Breaking Bad?
New show by...
Wait, I'm looking it up.
Wait, hold on.
Pluribus.
Oh!
Lady Yellen.
Post-apocalyptic science fiction TV show.
Whoa!
The most miserable person on earth must save the world from
happiness.
What is this?
What is this show?
Oh wow, it's kind of divisive, I feel.
The reviews show a lot of five-star and then quite a bit of
one-star.
Uh-uh.
It's really good.
There was...
There was one apocalyptic, post-apocalyptic show.
Oh, I think it was Last Man on Earth or something.
I think it got canceled before anything.
Yeah, Last Man on Earth.
I was watching that along, like, when it came out.
And...
I think I got canceled.
cancelled and never, uh, never, they never solved anything.
That's kind of what it reminded me of.
The synopsis.
Let's check it out.
Wait, is it on the Apple TV?
Oh, no.
This is pretty funny.
Yeah, I thought it was, I thought it was okay when I watched
it, yeah.
I saw, I saw a, a video that was like...
If a show gets cancelled, I feel like we are owed one final
episode.
You know what I mean?
Like, just some sort of...
I feel like they can at least...
They should at least give us that.
Like, something to just kind of explain things and wrap it
up.
Just...
Even if it's...
Like, you know...
I get it.
Like, if something is cancelled in between seasons, like,
that's so messed up.
For somebody who wants an ending.
Exactly!
Oh, man.
Do you guys see any moves I can do?
I'm trying to look.
I'm looking.
Give us a send-off, even if it's just to say your main actor
is unhinged.
I know!
Something!
Like, I feel like people deserve the closure.
The two on top.
Middle left, two, two, two.
This one?
Or, oh, this one?
Both of them.
How?
Where?
Huh?
Two on top left of three.
Yeah, but it's, how would I know?
Because it could be this or this or this.
It could be all three of those.
Night of your preference for proper resolutions.
How did you feel about Twin Peaks?
I have not watched it, Dan.
I have not watched.
To the right.
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
Oh, this one.
Oh, okay, okay.
Because...
Thank you.
Oh, it's a good thing we didn't do corners, huh?
Thank you guys, thank you, thank you.
Oh, oh, there we go.
Wait, no, just kidding.
But it has to be.
like that so one two three so this is safe yeah yes yes yes
okay okay okay then not safe then safe yeah click it anyway
click it don't you want to click it Okay.
Ah, we got that whole corner taken care of.
Let's go.
Thank you guys.
I didn't see that at all.
Anything here?
Good progress indeed.
Four on the right is open.
This one?
I'm starting drawing!
Give me three to four years, I'll design your bunny girl
outfit.
Yeah, you will!
Okay, I won't do a bunny girl outfit for three or four years
then.
Right above my mouse.
We're in the bottom left corner.
Should we try and get this corner down over here then?
It's kind of scary here though.
Oh, I can do this too.
This one?
Okay.
Boom.
And then boom, boom, boom.
One, two.
This must be this one.
Done.
Five.
One, two, three, four.
Oh wait, no, never mind.
You can finish the bottom left corner, start where the two
and three are.
Mm-mm.
Little Mouse with the 2 and 3.
Do you know, that's the funny thing about this game.
Is there many parts with 2 and 3.
But we can do it right there.
You're right.
I did end up seeing that one.
Let's see.
That actually clears up the 5.
So 1, 2, 3, 1.
Like this, right?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Skid Rock.
design a bunny girl outfit right now.
Bunny ears.
That's it.
No, nothing else.
You know, Ayami Mama, she made a bunny girl outfit, like a,
she did some fan art of Koharu wearing a bunny girl outfit,
and it's so cute, but she also made it into a clear file.
And the clear file, you guys, Ayami Mama's a genius.
The clear file has a separate part where the outfit is
overlaid on top and so when you open up the clear file
underneath is you know when you take off the clothes yeah I
love my mama you one two three Save.
We did another corner!
Oh my gosh.
We're about halfway through, you guys.
Minto cardboard bunny dress win.
Just like the red...
Cardboard!
I want to be properly dressed.
Thank you.
Alrighty, alrighty.
Placing my bet.
Mint will clear this before the timer hits 1000.
Trust.
Yeah, I will.
I will.
I...
Freestyle!
Yeah.
That was my superpower.
Um, this one must be.
Which means this one is clear.
Yes.
Which means this one is also clear.
Which means this one is bad.
Bad news bears.
Very important.
Leggings or no leggings?
What kind of leggings are we talking?
One.
Ta-da!
One, two.
Yes.
I like leggings.
I like stockings and fishnets and even like those like the
leg warmers.
I love those.
I love anything on a leg.
Stumped.
I'm looking.
I'm looking a little bit.
I might be a tad stumped, but Oh, I'll find it, maybe.
I might get it.
I mean to love leg.
Legs.
Feminine legwear is so cute.
It is, right?
A lot.
It's so many options too.
I have some Miffy leg warmers.
Yeah, I have many Miffy things.
Legs.
hmm
The two and four in the middle Right here Oh, this one,
da-dan, thank you.
You're right.
So one two three four Like that, right?
One two three four which means three is also good Thank you!
Thanks for the Super Chat too!
Thank you!
I wouldn't wear them, but I do love them.
You could wear them!
You could.
And then I like the big Gyaroo socks.
They are very long, but then you like scrunch them down.
I like those too.
Good old Gyaroo fashion.
Loose socks.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
One, two.
Just speak of my language.
Guarumito.
That would be fun.
I wish I could have a new outfit every week.
Two twos by the four.
This area?
Let me look a little.
Let me...
Perceive?
Or do you mean this area?
Oh, this one is good.
This one's good.
Ta-da!
And then one, two, three.
Baba!
Wow!
Wowee!
Big open.
Yippee!
Ta-da!
Wah!
Must be this one.
Nice, nice.
Big progress.
big progress and then oh no this is this is good this one
though wow oh my gosh guys oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh
one two
massive bread Massive.
Da-dang.
Go, ghost girl, go!
I'm going, I'm going!
I love being dead!
Um, let's see now.
This one, this one.
Save.
75% there Oh my gosh The pressure The pressure is too much
Let's see, okay I'm kind of like jumping all around, you
know, a little bit
My eyes are All I see is Red and green and blue At least I'm
not colorblind I know that Okay, this 3 is safe too One,
two, three One, two, three...
Only with pink.
That was just my brain being a little silly.
That's not because I'm colorblind.
That was just me.
Being a little funny.
You know the one above the four is a flag?
How do we know?
One, two, three, it could be...
How do you guys know?
Oh, I see, because of this two.
Oh, you're right, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes, two, two.
Yes, so this one is safe.
So then this bad boy right there.
Wham, bam, thank you, ma'am.
I love a tutu.
Princess tutu.
Oh!
Oh wait, I see a tutu.
Da-da!
Whoa!
Okay.
Hmm.
Yes, yes, very interesting.
And it has to be this one too, then.
One, two.
Yes.
Hmm.
Ugh.
It's so bright.
I wish I could turn out the brightness.
There needs to be like a dark mode.
Wait.
I wonder what display does.
Wait, what if I lose my game?
I'll try it after.
Yes sir I'll try it after Let's see
Minto are you ever doing another concert at anime NYC in the
future?
Thanks for the server chat I would like to If I ever get the
chance to I would But sometimes it's not so easy to just be
like I want to do this thing You know big bucks or to be
invited the two three two is free I don't know where you see
that or this one right here oh oh one two this one oh wait
no oh it is free because one two wait oh no just kidding
yeah one two three okay so that means
Bye-bye!
Monthly Minto appreciation!
Mirage!
Thank you!
Big, big money.
Large money.
Because 3D, well, I mean, it doesn't have to be 3D.
But for a show like Anime NYC, I would want to put in the
extra effort.
You know what I mean?
I would want it to be 3D.
what i want it to be because anime nyc is a big big event i
would want it to be also a big concert yeah lunari welcome
back thank you
let's see
uh this three is one two which means this guy is free one
two free see what I did there yeah
nice we will await your return to MIC with eager eyes and
pen lights in hand yeah and then hopefully too whenever I
return it's also with Phoebe and Vicky so we can do Denzitsu
concert da da da one One, two, three, four.
I have to double check everything, man.
You said free instead of three.
Very clever.
Yeah, yeah, I did, I did.
I should be saying safe.
I don't know why I'm saying free.
It's like I'm releasing it from its mortal coil.
You are free.
You are free!
Oh, I'm getting a little...
This area.
That chunk now requires harder deductions, I think.
Oh, really?
That's
a good way to not explode.
Do I have to guess?
No way.
No, why?
You got Spider Solitaire on that?
I love Spider Solitaire.
The three fields above the four are mines.
How do we know?
The space pinball.
Wait, that's so good.
You can deduce it.
Because the three means only one mine can be next to it.
Yeah, but why couldn't it be like that?
Like that one?
I don't know how you guys figure this out sometimes.
I'm still learning English.
You can only understand a little.
I absolutely love cute mint.
Supa-chan, thank you!
Thank you for watching, thank you!
English, go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-go-goo!
Got a bail!
Good night, Rebel!
Bottom left under the two, wait.
The two under the one will be safe in the middle.
Wait, oh, wait, too many words!
Too many words The one beside the three cannot be in mine So
the one beside the four must not be one
But why can't it be?
That's why I don't understand how you guys deduce these
Because it's like, you're like It has to be Like, you know
That's why K3 Okay, now you're speaking Now, okay this game
next week i mean last week what do you mean k3 what i what
is this battleships i sank your ship l1 k1 what is this
what is this
next week might be accurate accurate no no i know how to
play I know method of exclusion maybe I'll never be a pro at
mind sweeper then if I don't know how to do the exclusions
that's okay I just want to beat the game once queen to L1
who the one closest to the smiling face tells you that only
one bomb in the two spaces.
Yeah, I get that.
The two under tells you the one bomb, the top three spaces.
That means the third one.
Now you lost me.
Yeah, I know the rules, but not the strats.
I think that's a good way of putting it, because I really
get confused when you guys start saying things.
Don't say things are easy, because they're not easy for me
with numbers.
Thank you.
The one, I just need a lot of explanations.
The one four space, wait, the one four spaces from the
ghost.
Wait, what's ghost?
Me?
Wait, X sparks the spot.
Ah, okay.
Purple place?
Mind sweeper, 3D pinball.
No, I love solitaire.
Solitaire is my favorite.
I place, I have like, what's it called?
Solitaire on my phone.
I can play on the plane and that's like one time I had no
little TV screen on a flight to Japan and so it was just me
in solitary the whole time baby
okay there's so much text okay the 3 below 4 cannot have
more than 2 mines yeah because it already has 2 yeah the 4
must have 3 mines on top and 1 near the 3
okay okay okay uh that that helped explain I think okay I
get what your so the other one is a mystery we don't know if
it's this one touching three or that one touching three
I understand what you're putting down i get it okay okay
okay sometimes it's sometimes you guys will explain it in
seven different ways and only one way clicks for me you know
what i mean
one two three okay oh but this one has to be this one one
two three so then one two three four boom One...
Wait.
One, two, three...
Four!
Like that.
Wait, this is scary.
There's too many.
There's too many bombs.
Wait, yeah, that is right, right?
One, two, three, four, yeah.
There's too many bombs.
They're doing good though.
Thank you!
If it helps, there's a bomb on the bottom right of the
screen.
You are the bomb.
And the...
Okay, from here, though.
From here, though, it's pretty spooky, isn't it?
Apply the same logic to the one and two by the smiley face.
But...
But those have a one...
I don't know if this or this.
So then this one is free.
Is that what you're saying?
So this one is okay.
Okay.
I thought you guys were talking about where I place a flag.
So then this flag, this is flagged.
Because it's one, two, three.
Okay.
Tricky, tricky, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
And then this too is...
Okay.
When Microsoft stopped packaging Minesweeper and other games
with their OS, Windows 8, is when I knew Microsoft was done.
Give us the games we earned for the...
It's because they were like...
I bet you it was some old foggy.
that was like, hey, my salary men are playing games at work
and not working.
Get it out of there.
We yearn for the games.
We yearn for the mine.
Sweeper.
Okay.
This is spooky, scary, guys.
This is too scary.
This is hard When it gets really down to the wire You know
Skeletons, yeah Spooky, scary skeletons Wait a second, hold
on Two, two, this one's okay Wait, so that means
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da We did it Okay One, two Three.
Three is safe.
So many fours crammed into this area.
One, two, three.
Okay, one, two, three.
It would make most sense that it's this, right?
Four.
You can't get any more there right now.
Do we just...
do this one right here.
Guys, I don't want to get so far over here to where if I die
now, I die now.
I don't want to do all the work over here just to die in the
last two moves.
I don't want to do the right side yet.
I want to just die!
It's never going to change, you know?
we have like unless we do this whole area and then we have
one mine left you know what i mean
change tactics go to the twos and threes on the right i like
how i'm being directed okay fine fine we will divert course
Nah, I'm gonna press it.
That was scary.
Wasn't it guys?
That
was scary.
Yeah, it kind of doesn't help so much though, right?
A little bit.
It's still kind of tricky.
It still could be anywhere.
I feel.
Wait, you can solve it now.
Wait, does it?
Wait, how can you solve it?
This one is guaranteed safe.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's what I figured.
Because...
Okay, that means this one's safe.
Because 1, 2, 3...
Oh, yeah!
Wait, here we go!
1, 2...
Okay, wait.
Okay, hold on.
Uh...
This one.
Wait, the four?
What about the four?
So then this one, yeah.
We didn't need to come back at all, everybody.
Alright, now to the right side.
Hum, hum, hum, hum.
Tear.
Not another video takedown.
No gambling.
Oh.
You're right.
No gambling!
I don't condone!
Or wait, I say no to gambling.
I've never gambled once in my afterlife ever!
Oh, wait, this two is also...
I just realized.
Which means one here.
Okay.
And then also this two.
Which means this two is safe.
Okay, cool.
I'm a betting man.
Bet 10 gifted, you won't click the bottom right corner.
Just don't make baby noises.
Toes were mine.
Oh yeah, the two below here too.
I don't know.
I'm so far now.
I don't feel like I don't...
I'm scared.
I'm too scared.
I'm too chicken.
I'm chicken for real.
I'm chicken and out.
I am.
I don't believe in the corner method anymore Too much to
lose Too much to lose Uh, let's see here Uh, this one Nice
Which means this one's safe Nice Friends of the park Thank
you for the tech captain Thank you Oh Amito gambling is...
And crime is how I make all my money to Super Chai use.
Sometimes it's criminal gambling.
Sometimes gambling, criminal.
Okay, Walter White.
Thank you for the Super Chai.
And then we can also do this three.
And then two is safe.
And then must be this other two as well.
And then three is safe.
I messed up
I see where I messed up
I didn't see the other corner
I went too fast oh here's a good start
we can begin here
oh the dark mode yeah let me see let me see
wait it's it doesn't look so good for you guys though i
think it kind of looks weird for you guys huh it's it's fine
we don't need it it's fine it's okay it's okay that's fine
it was a big difference for me because the rest of the
screen turned dark, but it's fine.
It's fine.
I don't need it.
As long as you guys don't have your eyes hurting them.
That's all.
It's okay.
Okay.
I might be speeding through here a little bit.
One, two, three, four.
Yes.
I might be a little speedy.
A little speed demon.
Dark mode Mind Sweeper looks like a modern McDonald's
building.
What is that supposed to mean?
Look at her goal.
I'm on world record pace, mom.
I'll make it.
None.
I'm looking around.
Oh, here.
This one.
Do you guys hear that?
That was my tummy.
It went, wow.
I think I'm hungry.
I was gonna make ramen after this.
I want something salty, you know?
Did not hear.
Go eat?
That's too short.
We gotta beat the game, you guys.
We gotta beat the game.
I wanna be mine, sweeper.
I wanna do it.
Clear.
the three is near the center oh this one
south yeah i've been craving like a potato chip you know
something salty
careful of the 12 hour bond limit you are cruel i've only
i'm so mad about myself for the past game.
If only I had...
If only...
If only I had paid attention better.
But I guess that's the...
Gosh, if only...
It's one thing if you get...
Got by the 50-50, you know.
But if I had paid attention better...
I would have had it.
It would have been mine.
Victory.
It would have been my grasp.
Maybe.
Logan!
Thank you so much, motherfuck, it's a-
Anyone could have made that error.
Thank you.
The average person can physically live without food for
three weeks to two months.
How long can you last mentally not be the mind sweeper?
Food.
Not even once.
Okay, um, let's see.
Where?
The two is good.
I'm locked in I'm I'm I'm concentrating I'm concentrating
well locked in is like that's it maybe not locked in maybe
I'm like paying attention maybe I'm paying attention this
three can be done this one here yeah I'm slightly locked in
why would it I'm buckled up you know when you get in a car.
I'm buckled up.
But I wouldn't say I'm locked in the car.
Everybody wear your seatbelt.
She's strapped in.
Where else?
Here's a don't know towards the sodium food fund.
Stay salty, Minky.
Ectoplasm's salty?
Ectoplasm's not salty.
If you're salty, does that mean you're thirsty?
Maybe I need to stop drinking coffee.
Drink some water.
It's like a Baja blast.
Yeah.
Baja's blast.
Three next to the one he just did.
This guy!
Oh!
Yeah, I guess so, right?
One, two, three.
Yeah, we could just continue down the trend.
And then one is good.
Woo!
And there.
Nice.
And nice.
And you.
One, two, three, four.
Okay.
Are you learning to see the patterns?
I'll be honest.
No.
But...
Not...
entire like it's more so it's more so i am better at like
learning stuff about games like that when i'm not streaming
because my my stream brain is on right now so really
retaining things for me in this kind of environment is
difficult it's okay me neither okay good i'm glad i'm not
the only one
I think this one's safe.
No, I don't know.
I don't have no idea.
Hmm.
You are for sure just distracted a bit.
Yeah.
The
bottom right twos.
My brain is in watch mode, not backseat mode.
That's okay.
Thanks for watching.
Being a novice, you're as likely to imagine patterns as you
see them.
So, yeah, be careful.
Oh!
Did you just call me a noob?
Did you just call me a noobie?
You say, hey, little kid.
Watch yourself.
Watch your back.
Actually, I...
I am...
I'm just a poor little baby.
That was my first time playing Mind Sweeper.
Be kind to me.
Be kind.
I mean, it is true.
I'm just a poor noob.
Wait, this one is one, two, like that.
And then three, so it's safe.
Double one, two.
One, two.
Well, I don't have the three.
robs you the joy of pure gameplay fun.
Really?
Isn't that like how you're supposed to get better at the
game and learn how to do things?
Good luck you can clear all the threes on the right side,
but you will need to use process of elimination based on
location of the bombs with the numbers next to it.
Huh?
Oh wait, I was gonna say actually we could do that nope I
almost got toot again thank you for your help I forgot you
became a super expert from playing expert mode once last
week sorry sorry to hit pedal to hit pedal moment
oh this too that was my impression of a car
And then two is safe.
So accurate.
Now it's your transmission going.
Uh-oh.
This two is also okay.
It sounds very fast.
It is!
Whoops, there we go.
Oh!
Big moves, big moves.
Big moves, everybody.
Big moves.
Yes, yeah.
Oh, uh, yes!
Someone told me.
The Minto Mobile.
The Minto Pinto, except that should not happen to the Minto
Pinto.
Minto Pinto will live a long and healthy life.
We got this one right here.
You're a suit.
Did you know that this game was originally developed by Mine
S.
Weeper back in 1967?
Don't say that yet.
The Bite of 67.
Debbie Rye voice.
She's really good.
One, two, three.
Did I do that right?
Scared.
Nervous.
I'm shaking in my booties right now.
One, two.
Good so far.
Thanks.
Me, the minto of the mines, sweet burino.
What is your wisdom of the day?
My wisdom is...
Eat salt and drink water.
The Ford Pinto exploded whenever someone hit the back
because that was where the gas tank was.
It never happened to the Minto Pinto.
The advanced technique in Mind Sweeper is actually just like
in Nonograms, where you can color the tiles in between
possible extremes.
If you look at possible bomb locations, you may find some
tiles that are guaranteed even if you don't know the rest.
But Nonograms make a picture.
And sometimes I can guess.
Instructions unclear, drank seawater.
Oh do!
that.
Silly willy.
You're too silly.
Seawater will make you hallucinant and then you'll see
mermaids.
Which might be kind of cool.
Nah, don't look at this message.
No!
Ah!
Arrk, my mind.
I want to see mermaids.
I can siren you.
Coming to the world.
Water It's just the right temperature You know you wanna
swim in the water It feels really nice Come into the water,
you cute little sailor I'll show you how to swim
Follow me.
You'll never see your family again.
Guys, I'm jumping in.
Blub, blub, blub.
Not to swimming.
Where can I download Min Toes 95 to play this game?
Why?
I play on minesweeperonline.com.
Very easy.
Oh, oh, I was to say we could do this three but we cannot oh
this two is good though so we can do the three yippee safe
safe oh okay look at that everybody should think i'm cute
crash broken ship noises planks flying around
Whambo!
Kyaambo!
And then this three has to be like this, right?
Because one, two, three.
Which means one is safe.
Two is safe.
Two is safe again.
Ugh!
One, two, three!
Two is safe.
Let's see, let's do this abs.
Look, they got an 8-pack up going on here.
Look, if it were right underneath the Smiley, that would be
so good.
It would look just like an 8-pack on him.
Mr. Smiley, you've been working out.
You've been working out, huh?
All right, this 2 has to be like this.
1, 2.
which means this three is safe one, two, three and then one,
two okay, we don't know yet we don't know yet wait no one,
two this, oh wait, no the three is not safe It's always
these parts that get me tough!
Oh wait, this three is safe.
Okay, here we go.
One, two, three.
Wait, one, two, three, four.
Like so.
Right?
Possibly the first time in history someone has looked at
mine sweeper and thought, abs.
They should make this game easier for me specifically.
I want it to be where you reveal a picture underneath.
And it preferably be a naked anime lady.
That would really get me motivated.
One, two, three.
See, like, how are you?
Oh, it has to be this one.
It's not, this is the safe one.
Ah, I did
it.
Woohoo!
Okay, nice, very good.
Where should I go to now?
Hmm.
She's learning in streamer mode.
Streamer mode is on.
You need to be on the design team for video games.
I agree.
Binary Ghost, thank you for all the super chats.
Thank you!
You can use the logic with the 222 on the right To know it's
middle and bottom Oh, like this Ah, I see, I see Like, so,
oh wait
Where is your motivation?
I'm probably not sure there's probably an Edelgiver of Mind
Sweeper.
I think these ones confuse me the most because my brain is
always just like it could go any type of way I feel.
Andrew, thank you so much for the red!
Hello, hello!
Welcome in.
I claim VTubers as my dependents.
Oh, thank you.
The bottom 311 is easier.
Because it's like this, right?
Because we already have the one, two.
And it has to be connecting.
It has to be...
Well, this is where I...
Okay.
This is where I get confused, though.
There I go.
Thank you so much for the fact you did.
Like, why couldn't it be this?
Oh, and then like this.
You know?
That's why I get confused.
But which block is always safe?
Oh, this one?
Save.
Game dev Ibu, who is making a Minto Mind Sweeper, change it
to an Edo Game version.
Wait, wait, wait.
Or you could change it to just a full Edo Game version.
Yeah, that's okay.
It doesn't have to be me.
I'm starting to disintegrate.
Because I'm hungry.
Okay.
I feel like the two doesn't help so much.
You
can use the same technique to solve the left.
Up here?
But there's so many.
Use the MGS mind detector.
I wish.
lots of ones is good though yeah that's true well I mean yes
ones are good because they're easier to figure out I feel
but right now I'm kind of stumped
start from the top okay could be this or this well that's
the thing it's like I feel like for all of these I could be
like is this or this is this or this wait okay hold on if I
just I'm just gonna mark for my own visual i'm a visual
learner so it couldn't be this it can't be like alternating
right like you have to be one two one two like that top one
means the third isn't one that's true oh i get okay okay
okay okay okay i i it's it's clicking little by little
little by little so now if I erase
these little by little so this guy has to oh wait no he
doesn't have to be okay okay oh because there's already one
bomb where the three and two are on the bottom right to
complete the three there has to be a bomb above or below the
That means the three squares to the right of the two are
safe.
The three?
Oh, the three?
Huh?
So there's a bomb here or here?
Oh, you went this way!
Vertical, not horizontal!
Okay, okay.
I'm like, what do you mean?
that's crazy that's so much thought wow hello meeto today I
cosplayed you at hooters and converted the waitress into an
eye booth she has no idea what a youtuber is probably oh my
gosh it went to hooters if you were dressed as me then
technically that means I've been to hooters right what'd you
get what'd you eat
alright let's see Okay, I want to keep going back to this
one, though, because I'm trying to figure it out a little
bit.
So we cleared it up a little bit.
The wings were okay.
When are we getting a live stream from Hooters?
Hooters collab?
For leftmost one, the top or bottom must be one, corners.
So the left of them must be safe.
like oh okay I get it I get it oh you're right okay like
that I see I see I see I see why is it gotta be a 4 it's so
high wait but this one is also this oh wait just kidding
sorry oh my gosh how well so much okay so then
but it doesn't can I apply the same logic my brain hurts me
too
and then because but for the four we can do that because
it's still gonna be somewhere in the corners here okay okay
okay Booters is just America's version of Big Cafe, exactly!
Oh,
Big Bird.
No, no.
I'm still... still confused.
I'm still like...
Huh?
You know?
But here...
I think...
this is where i'm trying to figure it out because it can't
be like boom boom you know to hit up everything because then
it doesn't work with this guy so uh the two threes on the
left left the bottom threes i'm on it confuses me i'm i'm on
ones i'm not thinking twos and threes I'm on ones.
Which by the fours are definitely mines?
Well, like, this one would be one.
Or see, I'm like, is it this one or this one?
Wait, okay, hold on.
For this four, it has to be this one, these three.
It has to be boom, boom, boom.
So those are those are three.
Okay.
Wait, no.
Well, yes.
Right?
Yeah.
Because It can't be boom and boom.
Yes.
Yes, yes.
Okay, that is it.
That is it.
That is what I deduced.
Yes.
Then,
now the three above it.
Like this three?
well but how how it has to touch the one so oh wait wait
sorry these two are safe yes and then this one is safe and
so I'm guessing it's this and this and this is I was
incorrect.
Oopsie.
Well, I learned a valuable lesson.
I learned a valuable lesson.
Dang it.
Your honor roll just rolled a bit too fast.
me me me
me me
that's okay my goal for 2026 is to be mine sweeper meow
tower gives us bad guessing habits no!
Meow tower would never I never guessed in meow tower
value a boo lesson well guys I'm gonna end it here so that I
can go eat.
But thank you for helping me again.
I feel like I'm getting a little bit of the strats.
I feel like I'm definitely...
My brain is expanding.
It's growing one wrinkle at a time.
I'm not like the Grinch where my heart grows three sizes in
one session.
My brain will grow one wrinkle per session.
So please understand.
But thank you!
I feel like we didn't play so much of the game.
I feel like I yapped for so long.
I feel like I yapped more than I played, but that's okay.
Wait, wait, wait!
Hold on, guys.
I'm gonna do the Metal Gear method again.
Watch this.
Sweep!
Ah!
Watch this, watch this.
Sweep!
Oh!
Hello,
it's me.
Minto from the hospital.
Sorry, my lungs are filled with...
Uh, gas.
What you mean to everybody?
And remember, always, stay sweeping.